dieser fußballplatz im görlitzer
ortsteil hagenwerder ist trotz des
heißen sommers in einem top-zustand
jeder deutsche kreisligist würde von
einer solchen anlage träumen die
fußballer der sg hagenwerder klicken
hier seit über 40 jahren aber jetzt
dürfen sie nicht mehr auf ihren eigenen
platz
der absurde grund die stadt görlitz hat
ihn funktionstüchtigen dorfplatz
stillgelegt weil sie in sieben
kilometern entfernung das stadion der
freundschaft umgebaut hat also ich finds
unter aller sau was hier mit uns gemacht
wird falls ein verein ist wo viele
ehrenamtliche mitglieder da sind man war
natürlich in schockstarre und man hätte
eigentlich nur heulen können aber fühlt
man sich eigentlich um es mal ganz
deutlich zu sagen beschossen beim
hochwasser 2010 wird das spielfeld
erstmals seit jahrzehnten kurz
überschwemmt kein problem denn am
nächsten tag ist das wasser weg und der
platz wieder spielbereit doch die stadt
görlitz nutzt die gunst der stunde für
hochwasserschäden gibt es fördermittel
sie kassiert satte 1,2 millionen euro
das geld steckt sie in das stadion der
freundschaft und baute es aufwendig um
bedingung für die fördergelder der
funktionstüchtige sportplatz in
hagenwerder muss dicht gemacht werden
die fußballer fallen aus allen wolken ja
wir fühlen uns als bauernopfer war ja
für diesen ach so hochwassergefährdeten
platz der jahr überhaupt nie hochwasser
gefährdet ist die gelder genutzt werden
diese hochwasser satz worden die gelder
genutzt waren und in der stadt graz am
platz gebaut wird und der dafür
geschlossen werden soll
der oberbürgermeister kann die ganze
aufregung nicht verstehen die fußballer
können doch im neuen stadion spielen
die hat hagen werde nicht opfer tragen
dass er kein fußball spielt rund 7000
oder 8000 metern bis zum stadion
wir haben kein geopfert sondern wir
haben uns entschieden anstatt der
stadien zu sanieren hunderte von
sponsoren bei der sg hagen war da fühlen
sie sich komplett verschaukelt hier hat
keiner verständnis für den ganzen förder
ihr sinn
wie gesagt der film eigentlich die worte
dass wir einfach als kleine dafür büßen
müssen dass hier kein fußball mehr
gespielt werden kann
und ja das was anderes gebaut wurden wir
hier sein dürfen natürlich ärgert man
sich zu was man überhaupt hier
gearbeitet hat und wenn dann welche
kommt die hier nichts dazu beigetragen
haben und dann sagen einfach so wird
stillgelegt viel herzblut und zeit haben
die vereinsmitglieder von hagens weiter
ehrenamtlich in ihren platz gesteckt
alles für die katz denn bald können sie
hier nur noch den blumen beim wachsen
zusehen